GUTFELD.
IT IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS THE "THE FIVE."
THE BORDER CRISIS COMING TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S FRONT DOOR
BRACING FOR SURGE IN ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS ONCE THE TITLE 42
POLICY ENDS, WHICH ALLOWS BORDER
OFFICIALS TO DEPORT LARGE GROUPS
OF MIGRANTS.
GREG ABBOTT ANNOUNCED A PLAN TO
BUS MIGRANTS FROM HIS STATE TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., CONCEDING
TODAY IT WOULD BE VOLUNTARY.
>> JOE BIDEN REFUSED TO COME SEE
THE CHAOS HE'S CREATED BY OPEN
BORDER POLICY, WE'LL TAKE THE
BORDER TO HIM.
WITH REGARD TO VOLUNTARY
COMPONENT OF IT, DANE AIF I WERE
TO GO TO WASHINGTON, D.C. AND
TAKE YOU AND PUT YOU ON A BUS
AND TAKE YOU DOWN TO THE RIO
GRAND VALLEY, THAT WOULD BE
KIDNAPPING, SAME THING APPLIES
TO ANYBODY WHO REFUSES TO GET ON
A BUS, IT WOULD BE KIDNAPPING,
EVEN THOUGH IT IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
>> Dana: THE WHITE HOUSE HITTING
BACK AT GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S
ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> THE TEXAS GOVERNOR SAYS HE
WILL BUS BORDER CROSSERS TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., WHEN THEY GET
HERE, ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO HELP
THEM FIND A PLACE TO STAY AND
SOMETHING FOR THEM TO DO?
>> Press Sect. Psaki: I'M NOT
ARK WEA
AWARE OF WHAE
GOVERNOR WOULD BE DOING THIS
UNDER, I KNOW THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS OR ANY STATE DOES NOT HAVE
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO COMPEL ANYONE
TO GET ON A BUS.
>> Dana: REPUBLICANS ARE NOT THE
ONLY ONES SOUNDING THE ALARM ON
TITLE 42, DEMOCRATS ARE RAISING
CONCERNS WITH WHAT ENDING THE
POLICY WILL DO TO THE STATES,
MANY ARE IN TOUGH RE-ELECTION
RACES, BUT NOT ALL.
>> Jesse: IF I CAME FROM EL
SALVADOR AND I MADE IT TO TEXAS
AND THEY PUT ME ON A BUS TO DC,
I WANT TO GO BACK TO EL
SALVADOR, HAVE YOU BEEN DOWN
THERE RECENTLY IN THEY GOT TO
CLEAN THAT PLACE UP.
SHELLENBERGER SAID ON THE ROGAN
SHOW, WHICH I'M LISTENING TO
NOW, NOD BAD, THE 4R69 IS
OBSESSED WITH RADICAL
HOSPITALITY, THEY WILL ALLOW
PEOPLE TO SHOOT UP DRUGS IN
MIDDLE OF THE STREET OR WALTZ
INTO THE COUNTRY WITH THEIR
HANDS OUT.
PARENTS LET KIDS DO WHATEVER
THEY WANTED AND THE KIDS TURNED
INTO DISASTER, THAT IS WHAT JOE
IS DOING TO THIS COUNTRY.
THE FEDS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMMIGRATION, THE STATES CAN'T
JUST LAY DOWN, THEY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
ABBOTT HAD OPERATION LONE STAR
UNVEILED LAST YEAR, WHERE THEY
PUT ABOUT 10,000 NATIONAL GUARDS
DOWN TO THE BORDER TO NAIL
PEOPLE FOR TRESPASSING ON
PRIVATE PROPERTY.
IT IS COSTING A FORTUNE, NOW HIS
HANDS ARE TIED, HE CAN ONLY DO
SO MUCH, THIS IS A STUNT TO
EMBARRASS THE PRESIDENT TO DO
HIS JOB.
THEN THEY GIVE THEM PHONES,
FIRST THEY HAVE THE OBAMA PHONE,
NOW A BIDEN PHONE.
WHAT DO THEY GIVE THEM, LIKE
SIGNED COPIES OF "HOW I SAVED
THE WORLD," I MEAN, HOW MUCH
FREE STUFF ARE THESE PEOPLE
GOING TO GET?
GIVE THEM $1000, AIRFARE AND A
PHONE, CAN THEY TWEET, HASHTAG I
MADE IT.
THIS IS ABSURD AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT.
YOU DON'T NEED A PHONE TO TRACK
PEOPLE, DO YOU?
RIGHT?
WHEN YOU GO TO THE DELI AND YOU
TRY TO GET IN LINE, THEY GIVE
YOU A SLIP OF PAPER, THAT IS ALL
YOU NEED.
WHAT THE DATE IS AND WHERE TO
SHOW UP, IF THEY ARE TAKING THIS
SERIOUSLY, THAT DATE IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT DATE OF THEIR LIVES, I
THINK THEY CAN COMMIT IT TO
MEMORY, AND IF THEY ARE USING
THE PHONE AS A TRACKING DEVICE,
GOOD, IF THEY DON'T SHOW UP, GO
FIND THEM AND DEPORT THEM.
THEY ARE NOT DOING THAT.
>> Judge Jeanine: THEY CAN'T.
>> Jesse: LEGALLY MAYBE NOT, BUT
THEY SHOULD.
JOE BIDEN HASN'T BROKEN RECORDS
ON ILLEGAL ENTRIES, HE'S BROKEN
RECORD BY DEPORTATION, OPENING
THE PORT IS THE BEST THING HE'S
DONE --
>> Dana: IS THIS YOUR MONOLOGUE
FOR TONIGHT?
>> Jesse: NO, COME ON.
>> Dana: COME ON.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
JEN PSAKI TALKED ABOUT THE
PHONES TODAY.
>> Press Sect. Psaki: TAKE STEPS
TO ENSURE WE KNOW WHERE
INDIVIDUALS ARE AND WE CAN TRACK
AND CHECK IN WITH THEM, THE
ALTERNATIVE TO THE TENSION
PROGRAM, THIS IS WHAT WE UTILIZE
IS TECHNOLOGY TO MONITOR
PARTICIPANTS ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM.
>> ANY CONCERN THE MIGRANTS WILL
TAKE THE PHONES AND TOSS THEM?
>> Press Sect. Psaki: DO YOU
HAVE A RECORD OF PEOPLE THROWING
PHONES AWAY?
>> Peter: I'M JUST ASKING IF
THAT IS A CONCERN.
>> Press Sect. Psaki: OUR
CONCERN IS INDIVIDUALS WHO
MIGRATE TO THE UNITED STATES
PROCEED THROUGH OUR PROCESS OF
BE WILL MONITORED AND
PARTICIPATING IN HEARINGS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO STAY.
>> Dana: JUDGE, WHAT DO YOU SNNG
>> Judge Jeanine: THIS IS
POLITICAL THEATER, THAT IS ALL
IT IS.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BY ENDING
TITLE 42 IS BEING RECKLESS WITH
THE ECONOMY, WITH NATIONAL
SECURITY, AS WELL AS WITH OUR
HEALTH.
BY MAKING SURE THAT WE STILL
HAVE KIDS MASKED IN SCHOOLS
WHILE THEY HAVE BEEN COMING TO
THE BORDER SINCE JANUARY OF 2021
WITHOUT BEING TESTED, WHY ARE
THEY BEING TREATED DIFFERENTLY?
THE THING MOST INTERESTING ABOUT
THE PHONE, GIVE THE GUYS A PHONE
AND SHE SAYS, SO WE CAN CHECK IN
OR TRACK THEM.
THE WAY THEY PLAN ON DOING IT IS
WITH SOME KIND OF BIOMETRIC,
THEY ARE SAYING THEY TAKE THE
VOICE IMSXRINT CAN BE SURE THE
PERSON WHO ANSWERS THE PHONE IS
THE PERSON THEY GAVE THE PHONE
TO.
THAT IS HOG WASH, I TELL YOU
WHY, THEY DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE IN THE HOMELAND
SECURITY TO MAKE THE PHONE CALLS
TO CHECK IN ON THEM, THEY DON'T
KNOW WHERE THEY ARE OR IF THEY
THREW THE PHONE AWAY.
THEY DON'T KNOW IF THE PHONE IS
CHARGED OR NOT CHARGED, THIS IS
THEATER.
HERE IS THE QUESTION, WHAT IS
THE PRESIDENT'S END GAME HERE?
THEY GIVE EXCUSES LIKE YOU
AMERICANS, WE'RE GOING TO SHUT
YOU DOWN ISSUE BUT YOU ILLEGALS
COME THROUGH, WE DON'T CARE WHO
YOU ARE, IF YOU ARE MS-13, WE
WILL NOT DISCRIMINATE.
THEY SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU
NEED ASYLUM, YOU ARE COMING TO A
DAY, WHICH I FIGURE IT ALMOST
150,000 A WEEK, ABOUT 300 --
WHAT, 600,000 A MONTH WE'LL BE
ABLE TO HAVE THEM CALL AND WE'LL
CALL THEM BACK?
WHO WILL PAY FOR THIS?
WE ARE.
WHAT IS JOE BIDEN'S END GAME?
WHAT IS HE LOOKING TO ACCOMPLISH
IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> Dana: JESSICA, DO YOU WANT TO
ANSWER THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK THIS IS WHERE
JOE BIDEN WANTS TO BE.
THERE HAS BEEN PRESSURE FROM
IMMIGRATION GROUPS FROM THE LEFT
WING SAYING WE NEED TO GET RID
OF TITLE 42, A PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE ISSUE NOT AN IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
THIS WAS PUT IN PLACE WHEN COVID
STARTED SWEEPING THE WORLD TO
MAKE SURE WE WERE NOT LETTING
PEOPLE IN WHO WERE INFECTED WITH
THE DISEASE BEFORE WE HAD
VACCINATIONS, FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
JOE BIDEN IS PART OF MODERATE
DEMOCRATS, INCLUDING HILLARY
CLINTON AND OTHERS TALKING ABOUT
STRICT BORDER REQUIREMENTS, I
DON'T THINK THIS IS HIS NATURAL
POSITION ON IT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PEEP WHOLE
DO SHOW UP FOR THE MOST
IMPORTANT DAY OF YOUR LIFE,
LARGE PERCENTAGE, MAJORITY, OVER
90% OF THEM N. TERMS OF CALLS, I
DON'T THINK IT WILL WORK THAT
THEY HAVE A PHONE AND STAFF TO
DO THAT, WE NEED COHESIVE
IMMIGRATION POLICY THAT WILL
SATISFY BORDER DEMOCRATS LIKE
KELLY AND CINEMA AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
PICKING ON TITLE 42 WHEN IT IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURE DOESN'T
GET US CLOSER TO THE POLICY.
>> Dana: JUST YESTERDAY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAID IF YOU
HAVE A STUDENT LOAN, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PAY THAT BECAUSE OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND TITLE
42, WE DON'T HAVE A CRISIS?
>> THE PROBLEM WITH THE PHONE
THING, IT IS A WASTE OF MONEY,
IT DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE IT IS
OUR MONEY, THAT IS THE BIG
PROBLEM, I'M FOR STRICTER BORDER
ENFORCEMENT, I WILL TAKE FIVE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS OVER ONE
GENDER STUDY GRAD ANY DAY.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THE PEOPLE, IT
IS ABOUT THE PROCESS.
WE ALL AMERICANS WANT THE SAME
GOAL, WE LOVE IMMIGRANTS, THEY
COME HERE AND BECOME BETTER
AMERICANS THAN SOMETIMES THE
AMERICANS WE GOT HERE.
WHEN YOU REPUBLICAN, YOU ARE
INTO THE IDEA OF A PROCESS OR A
SYSTEM, NOT JUST THE GOAL.
DEMOCRATS SUFFER FROM ONLY
HAVING GOALS AND NO SYSTEMS.
THIS IDEA OF TRANSPORTING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO DC OR
TEXAS IS KIND OF -- DC OR
DELAWARE, IT IS HOW YOU SHOULD
DEAL WITH LAND-LOCK PRIVILEGE,
BIG CITIES DELIGHT IN CHEAP
LABOR OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, SO
THEY SCOFF AT BORDER STATES WHO
ARE DRIVEN TO EXHAUSTION BECAUSE
THEY GOT TO DEAL WITH THE
PROBLEM RIGHT THERE AND OFTEN
CALLED RACIST FOR TRYING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
INVESTIGATION OF GATE, WHERE ONE
BORDER DUDE WAS DEMONIZED TRYING
TO CONTROL THE BORDER.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT THE DEMES
IGNORE, THEY DON'T SEE
REPURCONGRATULATIONS, THEY GET
PRIVATE SECURITY.
LOCKDOWN AND MATCH, THEY GET TO
GO TO THE FRENCH LAUNDRY AND
TAKE SELFIES WITH THE
CELEBRITIES, I LIKE THE IDEA
OF -- IT HAS TO BE POSSIBLE,
SOME PEOPLE WOULD GET ON THE
BUS.
DELAWARE IS A NICE PLACE, I'VE
BEEN THERE, DC, THERE ARE NICE
NEIGHBORHOODS, DEMOCRATS
SHOULDN'T COMPLAIN, THEY WERE
INSTIGATORS WITH THE SANCTUARY
CITIES.
>> Judge Jeanine: ONE THING JEN
PSAKI SAID, SHE SAID NEARLY 80%
OF NONCITIZENS RELEASED AT THE
BORDER UNDER PROSECUTORIAL
DISCRETION RECEIVED NOTICE TO
APPEAR OR ARE WITHIN THE WINDOW
OF THE REPORT, THAT IS NOT IT IS
CASE.
80% OF ILLEGALS TOLD SHOW UP AT
THE IMMIGRATION OFFICE, ARE NOT
COMING IN AND TWO STUDIES SAY IT
IS MORE LIKE 83% ARE NOT
REPORTING AND 80% ARE NOT
REPORTING, THAT IS ALL THEATER
THERE.
>> Dana: YOU HAD SECRETARY
MAYORKIS SAY IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
PREDICT W